hey what's up guys it's Marcus Brahma
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
HD unboxing video and in this one I'll
be unboxing one of the smallest but yet
one of the most important products I've
unboxed on this channel so far and that
is the Zune HD
so let's get right on into this guys
so yes this is it this is the 16-gig
black Zune HD model I'll actually pick
this up a few hours ago at Best Buy for
$219 and I know a lot of you guys are
gonna leave comments or just be
wondering why did I get the Zune HD and
not something else like the iPod Touch
or another touchscreen multimedia player
well that is because I actually believe
right now that the Zune HD is really
what's best for me and I'm going to be
leaving us open to video responses of
why I should have gotten a different
media player or any other comparisons
you guys want to do a Zune HD versus
anything else and if I feel that it is
legitimate I will make a video response
to your video how about that so if you
guys have something to say against this
in HD I will do my best to defend it
play a little devil's advocate as I give
you guys a little tour of the box here
and show you it is the 16 gig black Zune
HD so let's just get right into the box
I know that's what you've been waiting
for I'll give you my honest first
impressions as well as show you guys
everything that you get in the box so
I'll just cut open both ends and uh here
we go now I've been excited to get this
player since I got my my new headphones
so um this is gonna be a pretty much
surprise for me as it is for you and uh
let's just open up the box here we go
break that tape there we go
here it is Wow small so here we go huh
the inside of the box is kind of a
vibrant orange if you can't tell it's
pretty neat and I will put this off to
the side and bring the Zune HD into the
picture so here is the Zune itself just
grab this tab right here and take it out
I will be putting a wrap cyl on this as
soon as I'm done with this video
so it'll never have any scratches on it
but it is a very nice looking device so
I'm just gonna put this to the side and
we'll continue with the box little Apple
s kind of thing going on here so there's
nothing actually in this cardboard
cardboard piece so I'm gonna back next
we have Zune everywhere so I'll open up
this and see what's in here
so we have a packet that says Zune
everywhere we open this up it's actually
a little poster that you guys want to
see that I'll include some links in
description to unboxing photos to show
you guys all these posters and their
full resolution next we have a 14-day
free trial for zoom Pass which I
actually already plan on getting so this
should be pretty nice for me download as
much music as you like for $14.99 a
month and actually be able to keep and
distribute 10 of those mp3s every month
pretty nice zoom net slash zoom pass
we'll put that to the side and keep
going looks like we have a little USB
symbol there if you guys couldn't tell
so this is the last thing that's in the
box and it says welcome to the social
one you so shall that's French and
that's it aside and we'll see what we
get in here looks like a little booklet
it says welcome to the Zune HD and again
the French version of it and another
little bit of a user's guide I'll put a
picture of that in the description we
have the Zune product guide which is
basically a bunch of manuals you know
these safety information all that good
stuff we have the USB synching cable
which is you know it's no good without
that we like the Chargers and needs D
and also there is wireless sync
available for the Zune HD but here's a
good look at the cable USB 2.0 over here
are the earbud foam tips or the earbuds
themselves these are the magnetic
earbuds so they will act as number one
the HD radio receiver and number two be
magnetic so that's pretty cool that it
will do that here are the tips you get
black on some pink and some orange
it's very crisp screen and this is the
first boot yet does have a little juice
and that looks really nice I'll have you
guys know and this is the player itself
so I'm actually just gonna go ahead and
put it put that wrap salon it I'll shoot
up a video of the wraps whole video in
HD and again we can turn this off ring
its back it's gonna be a pretty nice
little interface here I'll just open
that up so you can see it yeah it's
gonna be really nice guys so stay tuned
for more Zune HD videos stay tuned for a
few case reviews maybe a few application
reviews and I'll get back to you guys
with the full details of the Zune HD but
until then it's been Marcus Brownlee
from mkbhd everything you see and in the
description is what comes in the box and
I'll talk to you guys in the next video
thanks for watching peace